>> Tucker: 15 YEARS AGO,
FACEBOOK DIDN'T EXIST.
TODAY IT DOMINATES OUR LIVES,
SHAPES OUR CONVERSATIONS AND
DETERMINES HOW WE THINK.
AMERICANS SPEND CLOSE TO AN HOUR
EVERY DAY ON FACEBOOK.
THE COMPANY WANTS MORE.
FACEBOOK IS ROLLING OUT A NEW
APP MESSENGER FOR KIDS.
IT'S AIMED AS CHILDREN AS YOUNG
AS SIX.
MORE THAN 100 CHILD DEVELOPMENTS
EXPERTS SAY THIS IS A BAD IDEA
AND SERVES TO ADDICT KIDS TO
SOCIAL MEDIA EARLIER THAN EVER.
THE COMPANY SEEMS TO BE IGNORES
THAT.
JIM STIRE IS HERE.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
HAVE I MISCHARACTER SIZED THIS
APP AND WHO IT'S AIMED AT?
>> NO, YOU NAILED IT, THIS IS
ABOUT SOCIAL MEDIA FOR THE
KINDERGARTEN SET.
IT IS BASICALLY GETTING HOOKED
KIDS AT YOUNGER AND YOUNGER
AGES, 6, 7, 8, ON SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS LIKE FACEBOOK.
IT CRAZY.
WE DON'T NEED IT.
THAT'S WHY THE EXPERTS SUGGESTED
THAT.
>> Tucker: WE KNOW THAT HEAVY
SOCIAL MEDIA USE NEEDS TO
DEPRESSION, SOCIAL
MALADJUSTMENT.
THE IMPLICATION IS THAT IT CAN
HURT PEOPLE.
SO WHY WOULD FACEBOOK WANT TO DO
THIS?
>> BECAUSE IT'S IN THEIR OWN
ECONOMIC BEST INTEREST.
TRUTHFULLY YOU'RE TRYING TO HOOK
PEOPLE AT YOUNGER AND YOUNGER
AGES TO THE BRAND AND THE
CONCEPT.
IT'S A ECONOMIC INCENTIVE.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S MISSING OUT ON
ALL THE NEGATIVE ININTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT YOU REFERRED
TO.
THIS IS A NO-BRAINER FOR A
PARENT.
WHY WOULD YOU WANT YOUR
6-YEAR-OLD USING FACEBOOK OR
INSTAGRAM?
THIS SHOULD BE A NONSTARTER FOR
PARENTS.
>> Tucker: I'M SURE R.J.
REYNOLDS WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
NEW CIGARETTE THAT IS
KINDERGARTEN FRIENDLY.
ADULTS CAN DECIDE TO DO THAT IF
THEY WANT.
OUR SOCIETY DOES NOT ALLOW
CIGARETTE MAKERS TO SELL TO
CHILDREN.
WHY DO WE ALLOW THIS FOR
FACEBOOK WHEN WE KNOW IT HARMS
THEM?
>> IT'S LIKE CANDY-COATED
CIGARETTE.
TO HOOK KIDS AT YOUNGER AGES.
IT'S NOT A GOOD IDEA AT ALL.
BRINGS UP THE BROADER ISSUE, HOW
DO YOU GET YOUR KIDS AWAY FROM
THE SCREEN, ENJOYING THE
OUTDOORS AND WORLD AROUND THEM?
YOU DON'T WANT THEM SITTING ON
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS IN
KINDERGARTEN OR AT ANY AGE.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
WE KNOW IT AFFECTS KIDS ABILITY
TO READ AND RETAIN INFORMATION
AND TO THINK CLEARLY.
SO IS THERE ANY LEGISLATIVE
EFFORT TO PULL BACK OR ARE WE
JUST PASSIVE IN THE FACE OF A
THREAT TO OUR CHILDREN?
>> NO, NO, ACTUALLY, TUCKER,
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD STUFF
COMING ON THIS KIND OF ISSUE.
THERE'S STUFF HERE ON THE WEST
COAST IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT
ADDICTION RESEARCH THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE AROUND SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS.
MUCH GREATER PRIVACY CONCERN
NOW.
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS TO TRY TO
EITHER ENCOURAGE OR REQUIRE
COMPANIES TO RESPECT THE YOUNG
KIDS IN THEIR AUDIENCE AND THAT
WILL GROW.
WE PASSED A BILL CALLED THE
ERASER BUTTON HERE IN CALIFORNIA